يتسع الصراع في الشرق الأوسط
بحلول الدقيقة التي شهد فيها هذا الأسبوع
تحولًا مذهلاً وربما خطيرًا للأحداث حيث شنت إيران ضربات
ضد كل من باكستان والعراق قائلة إنها
كانت تستهدف الإرهاب في كلا البلدين،
ثم ردت باكستان على إيران
وهذا بالطبع  وبعد المزيد
من الجولات من الضربات الأمريكية على الحوثيين المدعومين من إيران
في اليمن وإسرائيل وحزب الله،
الجماعة المتمردة التي تعمل انطلاقاً من لبنان
بدعم من إيران، ظلت
تتبادل إطلاق النار عبر الحدود منذ
الغزو الإسرائيلي لغزة،
جلس وزير الخارجية الإيراني حسين أمير عبد لاهان.
انزل معي في دافوس يوم الأربعاء حيث
ضغطت عليه بشأن هذه التطورات،
اسمح لي الوزير أن أسألك لقد أتيت إلى برنامجي وبانا جريجا،
أجرت زميلتي مقابلة معك في 29 أكتوبر
وسألتك هل تريد انتشار المياه
وقلت لا نحن  لا نريد
انتشار المياه لا نريد التصعيد منذ
ذلك الحين حزب الله شن هجمات
ضد إسرائيل الهويس
يهاجمون أه السفن في البحر الأحمر لقد
هاجمت العراق لقد هاجمت
باكستان بالتأكيد يبدو أن
أفعالك إيران و  حلفاؤها
لا يوحي بأنك تحاول منع
هذه الحرب من الانتشار يبدو
وكأنك تشجع على
التصعيد أتفق معك غرب
آسيا الآن نشهد
اتساع الأزمة
والتوترات ولكن هذه التوترات ليست كذلك
تعود جذورها إلى ما حدث في السابع من
أكتوبر، حماس هي
مجموعة تحرير فلسطينية تقاتل
الاحتلال لتحرير
الأراضي المحتلة في
فلسطين، ونفذت عملية
بالطبع نحن لا نوافق أو نوافق
على قتل النساء والأطفال في
أي مكان في فلسطين.  العالم ولكن أريد أن أخبركم
أن الأمر ليس متجذرًا في ما
حدث في السابع من
أكتوبر، بل متجذرًا قبل 75 عامًا
عندما احتل
النظام الإسرائيلي فلسطين منذ بداية
حرب الإبادة الجماعية الإسرائيلية في غزة
والتي أعقبت حرب غزة.  عملية تشرين الأول/أكتوبر
أعطينا تحذيرات من أنه إذا لم توقف الهجمات
وجرائم الحرب والإبادة الجماعية ضد غزة والضفة
الغربية، فإن الحرب سوف
تتسع وتتسع، وهذا لا
يعني أننا أردنا أن نلعب دورا في
هذا
التوسيع